Well, it's a new week,
and I have a lot of questions.
And I'm gonna get them answered
right now
by someone who knows everything.
Alexa.
It's time for "Ask Alexa."
♪♪
-♪ Ask Alexa ♪
-Now, this -- I'm just
gonna talk to the Alexa.
-The Alexa. Great.
-And we'll get it going.
-Is that the microphone?
What is that?
-No, this is the --
this is the Bluetooth.
-Oh. Bluetooth plug. Okay.
-The Bluetooth -- No.
This is the --
Yeah, this is the micro--
CB radio.
[ Laughter ]
So you know that
it's really plugged in.
-Yeah. It's a real thing.
This is not a comedy bit.
-No. This is not a comedy bit.
This is real life.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Let me think
of some random questions.
Here is the first one.
Alexa, how far away are we
from Christmas?
-Alexa: We are 49 days away
from Christmas.
Unless you're CVS.
Then it's already Christmas Day.
-That's true. Yeah. That's true.
She knows.
-These are off
the top of your head?
These are just off the top
of your bean?
-Yeah. You want me --
-Ask another one. Yeah.
-Alright. How about this one?
I'll just take this out now.
[ Laughter ]
Now it's full-on wireless.
-Full-on wireless. Yeah.
Ooh, it's a rolling. Alexa.
-Yes. How about this one?
Alexa, what movie should I see
this weekend?
-Oh.
Alexa:
"Five Nights at Freddy's."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Isn't that the one
where robots kill people?
-Alexa: Yes. It's the feel-good
movie of the year. Ha ha ha.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How about this one here?
Alexa, whose slogan is
"you're in good hands"?
-Alexa: That's easy.
Lauren Boebert.
-Hey! Come on. Hey.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Beetlejuice!
-Alexa.
[ Laughter ]
...funny here. Alexa, what age
do people stop growing?
-Alexa: Most people reach
their full height by age 20,
except for rare cases
like Ron DeSantis,
who is continuing
to get taller at age 45.
-Fascinating.
[ Applause ]
-Hey.
-These are all great answers.
You're just asking
random questions.
-Yeah. Alexa, how can people
save enough money
for retirement?
-Alexa: You will save
enough for retirement
if you cancel literally
one streaming service.
-There you go. Just one.
-Yeah. Just one.
-How about this one?
Alexa, how do most people
find fulfillment?
-Alexa:
Most people find fulfillment
with Olive Garden's
unlimited soup and salad.
-Pretty good.
-Not breadsticks?
-She's right.
-Let's ask one more question.
Alexa, can you order me tickets
to Taylor Swift Eras tour?
-Alexa: You've got to be
[bleep] kidding me.
Now, can we end this bit
so we can get to Jungkook?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it.
That's all the time we have
for "Ask Alexa." Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." What...